oh hi I didn't see you there Oh oh my
god you pulled my headphones out which I
guess I don't need to be wearing right
now anyway so it's fine
lesson learned has been not as effective
as initially anticipated but really good
morning everyone I'm making a very quick
video today basically I am joining the
kind of funny family not full-time for
the record this isn't like I'm not just
this isn't me announcing that I'm
leaving fun house and inside gaming and
going to work to kind of funny this
would be social weird way to do that no
basically I'm going to be walking with
kind of funny for the next six weeks
could extend beyond that we don't know
on a brand new show because I need more
podcasts in my life apparently but yeah
myself and Gary Whitta who you might
know as the writer of rogue one as well
as I guess kind of funny community
members snow bike Mike I still don't
know his real name first name snow bike
last name Mike I presume who is actually
going to be show writing the show
teaming up to make an xbox podcast for
the next six weeks every Saturday at 6
a.m. the kind of funny X cost as it is
cold will go live on youtube.com slash
kind of funny games let me check that
real quick make sure it's kind of funny
I was right and also on podcast services
where basically yeah this is kind of
funny story and having an Xbox specific
show they already have a PlayStation
show I guess for anyone who doesn't know
who kind of funny is let me pull up
there in food yeah I guess there are
another kind of YouTube channel that
exists in the same space that inside
gaming does and that that kind of a
hybrid of games media and youtubers if
that makes sense but yeah they do
reviews daily podcast literally news
podcasts about video games every single
day that's a kind of funny games daily
that playstation show is called PS I
love you and yeah this is the launch of
the Xbox show kind of funny X cost so
yeah it's kind of like a six week pilot
I guess the three of us every week
talking about Xbox leading into that
press conference so our first episode
actually goes up this Saturday and then
I'm sure we'll have that reaction to the
conferences and yeah I'm excited to be a
part of it as someone who is very
enthusiastic about a lot of Xbox
franchises see a big Fable fan I'm a big
ears fan
big Halo fan I'm a big perfect dark fan
except for zero which you know so I
guess I'm like 50% of a big perfect dog
fan I'm also really more of a fan of
favor the Lost Chapters than the others
but well we'll get into that in the kind
of funny X cast oh they didn't ask me to
make this video I just thought that I
would announce it for you guys because I
I realized that I have made this habit
of announcing things on other social
media platforms and not on YouTube but
this is a show that will be on YouTube
so it makes sense to announce it here as
well I will leave a link in the
description below its where you can find
kind of funny again
not sponsored I was not asked to do this
I just asked to so yeah join us talk
about Xbox for a good six weeks it
should be a good time I hope to see you
guys there if not and you don't care
about this video at all and you're like
why did I click on this that is fair let
me tell you a fun fact did you know that
Australia has the world's longest golf
course measuring more than 850 miles
long I didn't know that until right now
Australia is home to 21 of the world's
25 most venomous snakes I did know that
one there are a lot of them PUF is the
only city in the world which can have an
aircraft land and it's CBD how does that
walk Perth what each week there are an
estimated 70 tourists that overstay
their visas Wow anyway can you tell I'm
homesick all right you guys this is we
had maybe all the Deadly Premonition -
I've been playing is she's been rubbing
off on vacation I'll see you guys next
time